ken and Isaiah are eating pumpkin pie
with their friends they want to figure
out how much pie they have eaten so far
there are seven of them in total and
each of them has eaten two-fifths of a
pie ken said you can solve this problem
by multiplying 2/5 times 7 and that
makes sense each of them a 2/5 and
there's 7 folks I would multiply 2/5
times 7 so he multiplied and got 14 over
35 now this is a little bit suspicious
and here is the work that he did he said
2/5 times 7 is equal to 2 times 7 over 5
times 7 which equals 14 35 so this is
starting to smell real fishy right now
Isaiah says that 14:30 fifths cannot be
correct because 14 30 fifths is less
than one whole pie so this is definitely
true that 14 30 fifths is less than one
whole pie which of the following best
explains this situation so let's before
even looking at the explanations let's
see what's fishy about this so let me
get my little notepad and write it out
so he literally took 2/5 and he
attempted to multiply it by 7 and he
said that this is the same thing as
taking the 2 times the 7 over the 5
times the 7 and that's how he got the 14
over 35 I encourage you to pause this
and try to figure out why this doesn't
make sense yourself now let's think
about what actually went on here if you
multiply 2/5 times or if you multiply 7
times you multiply the numerator times 7
and the denominator by 7 you're actually
not changing the value of the fraction
this is equivalent to saying 2/5 times 7
over 7 which is the equivalent to 2/5
times 1 which is equivalent to 2/5 14
over 35 is just another way it's an
equivalent representation of 2/5 this is
just how much pie
only one person should have eaten so how
should he have thought about this well
there's a couple of ways you could think
of it 2/5 times 7 could literally mean 7
2/5 it literally could mean so 2/5 times
7 literally means 1 2/5 plus another 2/5
plus another 2/5 so we do this 7 times
so that's 4 2/5 that's 5 2/5 that's 6
2/5 and that's 7
two-fifths sorry my brain isn't working
and that's seven two-fifths and if you
were to add all of these together how
many fifths do you have how many fists
do you have well you have two plus two
plus two plus two plus two let's see
that's five plus two plus two you have
to seven times fifths or this is another
way of saying you have seven times let
me write it this way you have two times
seven fifths or another way of saying is
this is equal to fourteen over fourteen
over five and this is more than this is
what well over more than one five goes
into 14 two times and you have remainder
of four so it's two and four fifths hi
so this is what he should have done but
you might be saying well you know this
is well how would I just multiply this
if I didn't even have to think it
through all of these adding all these
two fists together well one way to think
about it is that seven is the same thing
as 7 over one so he could have just said
2 over 5 times 7 over 1 7 over 1 is the
exact same thing as 7 and that would be
equal to 2 times 7 in the numerator
which is 14 and the denominator would be
5 times 1 which is equal to 5 and you'd
get the same answer so now let's
actually go back and select the right
choice I forgot that we actually had to
see which which explanation is the right
explanation so explanation 1 is that Ken
didn't multiply correctly multiplying
2/5 times 7 is the same as adding 2/5 7
times this is exactly right this is
exactly what we just went through the
correct answer is 14 5th or 2 or 4 v 2
and 4/5 so explanation a seems to be the
right one but we'll just read the other
ones just to see if there's some flaws
in them explanation B can multiplied
correctly but forgot to cancel out the
7s in the fraction since 7/7 is equal to
1 - v times 7 is equal to 2/5 times 1
well obviously 2/5 times 7 is not the
same thing as 2/5 times 1 so this is
kind of nutty explanation see since ken
must add up all the pie for 7 of them he
should have added 7 and 2/5 instead of
multiplied
makes no sense he should be multiplying
ken is correct this Francis should need
that much pine oh that's that's that
doesn't make sense either it's
explanation a